Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Raise the flag, the ranks tightly closed, the SA marches with calm, steady step. Comrades shot by the Red Front and reactionaries march in spirit within our ranks. Clear the streets for the brown battalions, clear the streets for the storm division man millions are looking upon the hooked cross full of hope the day of freedom and of bread dawns for the last time the call to arms is sounded for the fight we all stand prepared already hitler's banners fly over all streets the time of bondage will last but a little while now.
感谢收听《历史其余》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员。网址是 therestishistory.com。举起旗帜，队列紧闭，冲锋队迈着平静而坚定的步伐。被红阵线和反动派射杀的同志们在我们的精神队列中行进。为棕色营清空街道，为百万冲锋队队员清空街道，无数人正满怀希望地凝望着带钩的十字，自由与面包之日最后一次破晓，战斗的武装号令已经吹响，我们所有人早已严阵以待，希特勒的旗帜已经在所有街道上飘扬，奴役的时代现在只剩下很短的一段时间了。
Those are the English translation of the Horst Vessel song, which Dominic, I think I'm correct in saying, ended up kind of the anthem of Germany, didn't it? Along with Deutschland Uber Alley's Once the Nazis Had Taken Power. And it was, of course, written by a man called Horst Vessel. So hence its name. And Horst Wessel is pretty much the only time I've ever written about the rise of the Nazis, because he featured in Dominion. And as I was writing about Horst Wessel, I was kind of obviously looking at, you know, echoes of parodies of Christianity. And I hadn't fully appreciated the background to the story, which is what this episode is basically about. So it's the process by which the Great Depression hits Germany, street fights between the Nazis and communists intensify, and towards the end of it,
这些是《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》的英文翻译，多米尼克，我想我没说错吧，它最终基本上成了德国的国歌，对吗？在纳粹夺权后，与《德意志高于一切》并列。当然，它是由一个名叫霍斯特·威塞尔的人写的。所以它也因此得名。霍斯特·威塞尔几乎是我唯一一次写到纳粹崛起时涉及的人物，因为他在《统治》（Dominion）一书中出现过。当时我在写关于霍斯特·威塞尔的内容，很明显，我注意到了一些基督教的迴响和对基督教的恶搞。我当时还没有完全理解这个故事的背景，而这正是本期节目主要讲述的内容。所以，这是一个大萧条袭击德国、纳粹与共产党人之间的街头冲突愈演愈烈、并在这一过程接近尾声时，
we move towards Hitler actually taking power. Yes. So hello, everybody. Last week, we did two episodes about the rise of the Nazis. So the origins, the intellectual and political origins of Nazism, and then the story of Hitler in the 1920s, for much of the 1920s. And this episode is the sort of the crunch point, I suppose, is the point at which the Nazis take power. So we left them with the Nazis as a small party, but expanding, particularly in the Protestant countryside in the late 1920s against the backdrop of the Weimar Republic. United under a leader in Adolf Hitler who has the gift of the gab and has become convinced that he is the man of destiny who will lead Germany to greatness. And Tom, you were very keen to talk about Horst Wessel. So Horst Wessel is a young man who joins the Nazi party in, I think, 1926. So it's round about the time that we ended the last podcast. Is that right? Yes. Yeah. I just thought it would be interesting just to zoom in because we've been, you know,
我们走向希特勒真正夺权的过程。是的。大家好。上周，我们做了两期关于纳粹崛起的节目——也就是纳粹主义的起源、思想和政治起源，然后是20世纪20年代大部分时间里希特勒的故事。而这一期节目可以说是转折点、决战点，即纳粹夺权的那一刻。所以上期节目结束时，纳粹还是一个小党派，但正在不断扩张，特别是在20世纪20年代末魏玛共和国的背景下，在新教乡村地区。他们在阿道夫·希特勒这位领导人的团结下，他能言善辩，并且已经坚信自己就是那个将带领德国走向伟大的天命之人。汤姆，你非常热衷于谈论霍斯特·威塞尔。霍斯特·威塞尔是一个年轻人，他在我认为是1926年加入了纳粹党。所以差不多是在我们上期播客结束的时候。是这样吗？是的。是的。我只是觉得，把镜头拉近一点会很有意思，因为我们之前一直在谈论的，
it's been a lot of kind of broad brush high politics. And I think the Horst Wessel story kind of highlights quite a lot of these broader themes. And at the end of episode two, you were talking about how the Nazis had a particular appeal for the young. And Vessel absolutely illustrates that. So you talked about Himmler, who was born in 1900, but Vessel is born in 1907. So he's joining the Nazi party age 19. He is also, he's very middle class. His father was a Lutheran pastor. And essentially, I think that Wessel discovers in the Nazis a sense of excitement and glamour and swagger and purpose that he is not finding in the church. In the previous generation,
都是一些宏观的大局高层政治。而霍斯特·威塞尔的故事很好地凸显了许多这样更广泛的主题。在第二集结束时，你谈到了纳粹对年轻人有着特殊的吸引力。威塞尔完全体现了这一点。你提到了海因里希·希姆莱，他出生于1900年，而威塞尔出生于1907年。所以他19岁就加入了纳粹党。而且他出身非常中产阶级。他的父亲是一名路德宗牧师。本质上，我认为威塞尔在纳粹身上发现了一种兴奋、魅力、神气和目标感，而这些他在教堂里是找不到的。在上一代人中，
he might have done, but not now. Like a lot of the young people that you were talking about in the previous episode, he has a feeling that he has missed out on fighting in the Great War. He was also, again, quite like, say, Goebbels or other leading Nazis. He was not physically prepossessing as a boy. He'd fallen off a horse and broken his arm. And so almost by way of compensation, he was obsessed with violence. He kind of taught himself martial arts, practiced boxing, all that kind of stuff. And he had this kind of, you know, going to school and then going on to university. He studies law in Berlin. He has this interest in street fighting.
他或许能找到，但现在不能了。就像你在上一集里谈到的许多年轻人一样，他有一种错过了第一次世界大战参战机会的感觉。而且，再次像戈培尔或其他纳粹高层一样，他作为一个男孩，外表并不出众。他曾从马orse（注：应为horse，原文误写为orse或拼写瑕疵）上摔下来摔断了手臂。因此，几乎是为了补偿这种心理，他对外在的暴力有着一种痴迷。他自学武术，练习拳击，诸如此类。他有这种——上学，然后上大学。他在柏林学习法律。他对街头斗殴产生了兴趣。
And when Goebbels comes to Berlin, Berlin is a very red Berlin. It's a very communist city. Goebbels recognizes in Wessel someone who can provide him with a spear point, driving it into the guts of the communist areas of Berlin. And Wessel brings some of those kind of Lutheran qualities to it. So that song, the horse Vessel song, it's written like a hymn. And Vessel is writing lots of these songs, and he's kind of hiring musicians, and they're marching through communist areas playing these songs, getting into fights.
当戈培尔来到柏林时，柏林是一个非常“红色”的柏林。这是一个非常共产主义的城市。戈培尔在威塞尔身上发现了一个可以为他提供一把尖刀、刺入柏林共产党人腹地的人。威塞尔将路德宗的一些特质带入了其中。所以那首歌，《霍斯特·威塞尔之歌》，它写得就像一首赞美诗。威塞尔写了很多这样的歌，他雇佣音乐家，他们行进通过共产主义区域，演奏这些歌曲，并卷入冲突。
And Vessel ends up being shot. He actually kind of gets shot in the face in his own room. And he kind of lingers in agony for several weeks and then dies. And Goebbels picks on him to play the role of a martyr. And I use the word advisedly because Goebbels, who comes from a Catholic background, deliberately echoes Christian iconography. He ends at the funeral service, he explicitly compares Vessel to Christ. Just reading your notes, extraordinary. A man who calls out through his deeds, come to me, I shall redeem you. A divine element works in him, making him the man he is and causing him to act in this way. One man must set an example and offer himself up as a
最终，威塞尔被枪杀了。他实际上是在自己的房间里被枪击中了面部。他在痛苦中煎熬了几个星期，然后死去了。戈培尔选中了他来扮演烈士的角色。我之所以用这个词是经过深思熟虑的，因为出身天主教背景的戈培尔，刻意呼应了基督教的圣像画。在葬礼仪式结束时，他明确地将威塞尔比作基督。我读一下你的笔记，太惊人了。一个通过他的行动呼唤着的人：“到我这里来，我将救赎你们。”一种神圣的元素在他身上起作用，使他成为现在的这个人，并促使他以这种方式行事。一个人必须树立榜样，并将自己作为
sacrifice. I mean, it's explicit, isn't it? It's not even- It's absolutely explicit. And I think that, you know, and in due course, Wessel will come to serve Nazis almost as a kind of God. You have girls in the 30s who go to kind of, you know, woods or the ruins of amphitheaters or whatever, and make offerings to Wessel if they can't get pregnant. I mean, it's very, very odd. Incredible. At the Nuremberg Rally, they sing, we don't follow Christ, we follow Horst Wessel. Yeah. So I think that that shows the readiness of the Nazis to construct a mythology that will be appealing. And I think that Wessel's own life shows that a huge part of what the Nazis offer to young men who are looking for a sense of purpose is a sense of drama, of action, and the kind of thrill of
牺牲奉献出来。我的意思是，这非常明确，不是吗？甚至都不是——这绝对是显而易见的。我认为，假以时日，威塞尔在纳粹心目中几乎会成为某种神一般的存在。30世纪（应指20世纪30年代）的女孩们会去树林里、圆形剧场的废墟或其他地方，如果她们怀不上孕，就会向威塞尔献祭。我的意思是，这非常非常诡异。难以置信。在纽伦堡集会上，他们高唱：“我们不追随基督，我们追随霍斯特·威塞尔。”是的。所以我觉得这表明了纳粹随时准备构建一种具有吸引力的神话。我认为威塞尔自己的人生表明，纳粹向那些寻找目标感的年轻人所提供的东西中，很大一部分是戏剧感、行动感以及
violence. And all of this is obviously happening against the backdrop of the Great Depression, which as conventionally told is what helps bring the Nazis to power and to what extent is that actually the case Dominic? Well as your story suggests I think Tom the Nazis would have always had an appeal in the kind of traumatized brutalized very unhappy neurotic landscape of 1920s Germany even if the economy had been doing much better so you know the people are somebody like Horst Wessel doesn't fight in the war looking for meaning, looking for belonging. Christianity doesn't offer that. It doesn't seem to offer that anymore. So it would have been a fringe appeal. But what transforms the Nazis' fortunes, I think,
暴力的刺激。这一切显然都发生在大萧条的背景下。按照常规的说法，正是大萧条帮助纳粹夺取了政权。多米尼克，这种情况在实际上究竟达到了什么程度？正如你的故事所暗示的，汤姆，我认为在20世纪20年代德国那种创伤深重、饱受摧残、极度痛苦且神经质的社会背景下，即使经济状况好得多，纳粹也始终会具有某种吸引力。所以，你看，像霍斯特·威塞尔这样的人参军并不是为了寻找意义，而是为了寻找归属感。基督教提供不了这一点。它似乎再也提供不了这种东西了。因此，它原本只可能是一种边缘的吸引力。但彻底改变纳粹命运的，
irrevocably, is the impact of the Great Depression. So Germany was always struggling in the 1920s, struggling with the burden of the First World War, as Britain is actually. But Germany has to pay reparations. But Germany has to pay reparations. It's had their hyperinflation, for which there's no real British equivalent. Germany has begun to recover by the second half of the 20s,
无可挽回地改变了局势的，是大萧条的影响。因此，在20世纪20年代，德国一直在苦苦挣扎，与第一次世界大战的重担作斗争，英国其实也是如此。但德国必须支付战争赔款。但德国必须支付战争赔款。德国经历过恶性通货膨胀，英国并没有真正与之对应的经历。到了20年代后半期，德国开始复苏，
but it's very dependent on loans from American banks. Right. So that makes it very, very susceptible to the crash. It's a terrible position to be in. So Germany is not unusual. Austria is the same, a lot of Central Europe. It's already got quite high unemployment by 1929, by the point at which you have the Wall Street crash in October 1929, which I mean, most of our listeners, I imagine, will be vaguely familiar with the stock market crashing apocryphal stories and they are apocryphal of people leaping out of the windows of wall street buildings and so on what what happens
但它非常依赖美国银行的贷款。没错。这使得它极易受到股市崩盘的影响。这是一个可怕的处境。所以德国并不特殊。奥地利也是一样，许多中欧国家都如此。到1929年时，失业率已经相当高了，正值1929年10月华尔街股市崩盘的时候。我的意思是，我想我们的听众大都对股市崩盘以及那些关于人们从华尔街大楼窗户跳楼的杜撰故事（它们确实是杜撰的）略有耳闻。那么发生了什么呢？
what definitely happens though is that american banks start to withdraw their money from central europe um and and that's quite a protracted process so that takes about a year or so to really, for the full horror of the impact to become apparent. So, I mean, Horst Wessel is shot in the beginning of 1930. And at that point, the Depression has not yet fully hit Germany. It fully hits in the spring and summer of 1931. So it's the collapse of the big Austrian bank, the Credit Anstalt, which I think at the time was the big austrian bank the credit and stelts which i think at the time is the biggest bank in central europe and then lot takes lots of other banks with it and
不过，确切发生的事情是，美国银行开始从漫长的中欧撤回资金。这是一个相当漫长的过程，大约需要一年左右的时间，其影响的全貌才会显现出来。所以，我的意思是，霍斯特·威塞尔在1930年初被枪杀。在那时，大萧条尚未完全冲击德国。它是在1931年的春夏之交才全面爆发的。当时是奥地利大银行——奥地利信贷银行（Credit Anstalt）的倒闭——我认为在当时，那是中欧最大的银行，随后它拖垮了许多其他银行，
so again that poor price is middle class who've had their savings oh i mean the stats are frightening so about one in three workers registered workers is out of work in germany by 1932 it's probably even worse in the big industrial heartlands in the rur and silesia um i think i got this from richard evans's book about 13 million people are in germany at this point so that's what you know a quarter getting on for a quarter of the population or so um slightly less, are living in households that are blighted by unemployment, where they're either dependents of people who don't have a job or they don't have a job themselves. You get a half million people homeless, people turning in their droves to prostitution, to
所以，那些失去积蓄的中产阶级又一次——我的意思是，统计数据是吓人的：到1932年，德国大约三分之一的注册工人失业；在鲁尔区和西里西亚等大型工业腹地，情况可能更糟。我想我是从理查德·埃文斯的书里看到这个数据的：当时德国大约有1300万人口，所以这意味着，你知道的，四分之一左右的国民人口，
begging, to crime, and so on. And it's the criminality, isn't it, for the Nazis and indeed for the communists, actually kind of heightens the sense that the streets are a battleground. So Horst Fessel, somebody like him, I mean, he's been drawn into kind of paramilitary politics, which has been there since the end of the First World War in 1918. But of course, when you have so many unemployed young men, you say to them, here's a uniform, here's a truncheon or a or a pistol come into the streets you know join us we are i mean that song that you i'm a thank god you didn't
生活在饱受失业摧残的家庭中，他们要么是失业人员的家属，要么自己就失业了。有50万人无家可归，人们成群结队地转向卖淫、乞讨、犯罪等等。正是这种犯罪行为，不是吗？对纳粹以及实际上对共产党人来说，这进一步加剧了街头沦为战场的这种感觉。所以霍斯特·威塞尔这样的人——我的意思是，他被卷入了准军事政治，这种政治自1918年第一次世界大战结束以来就一直存在。但当然，当你拥有如此多失业的年轻男性时，你对他们说：“给你一件制服，给你一根警棍或一把手枪，到街上去，加入我们。”你知道的，就是那首歌——那首你——谢天谢地你没唱它——
sing it um but it's like a kind of hyper militarized boy scouts anthem exactly right yeah i think that's exactly what it is um babylon berlin the tv series that we talked about the german brilliant german tv series we talked about in the last episode, captures this very well, that young men who are looking for something, who are sick of the old men's world, somebody gives them a belt. Excitement. A shirt, excitement, belonging, friends. The stormtroopers, they will go on camps and sit around the fire
但它就像是一种高度军事化的童子军赞歌。完全正确，是的，我想这正是它的本质。《巴比伦柏林》这部我们上集讨论过的德国高分神剧，非常完美地捕捉到了这一点：那些在寻找某些东西、厌倦了老头子世界的年轻人，有人给了他们一条皮带。刺激。一件衬衫，刺激、归属感、朋友。冲锋队，他们会去野营，围坐在篝火旁，
and sing songs and all of this sort of stuff. Now, the communists doing that this too so communist membership trebles between 1929 and 1932 unemployed the unemployed in particular is drawn to communism you can completely understand why the leader of the communist party sort of their answer to hitler if you like it's a man called ernst tellman who's a manual laborer from hamb. He, like Hitler, won the Iron Cross in the First World War. He's a pure classic communist revolutionary Stalinist. He's taking orders from Moscow. He absolutely believes in revolution. He believes in smashing the bourgeois parties.
唱歌等等诸如此类的事情。现在，共产党人也在这样做。共产党党员人数在1929年至1932年间增加了两倍。失业者，尤其是失业者，被共产主义所吸引。你完全可以理解为什么共产党领导人——可以说是他们对希特勒的回应——是一个名叫恩斯特·台尔曼（Ernst Thälmann）的人，他曾是汉堡的一名体力劳动者。和希特勒一样，他在第一次世界大战中获得了铁十字勋章。他是一个纯粹的经典共产主义革命斯大林主义者。他听从莫斯科的命令。他绝对信仰革命。他相信要粉碎资产阶级政党。
The communists hate the Social Democrats and the parties of Weimar. It's understandable why, because the Social Democrats had used the army against them in 1918, 1919. And so this is key to understand, isn't it? That the Nazis are... So Horsfessel is being sent in by Goebbels to rough up the communists and to provoke them and to generate street fighting against them. So for Horsfessel and Goebbels, the communists are the main adversary. But for the communists, even though they don't like the Nazis, if they're given the opportunity, they'll go up to Horsfessel's room and shoot him in the face.
共产党人痛恨社会民主党和魏玛的各政党。这是可以理解的，因为社会民主党在1918、1919年曾动用军队镇压过他们。所以，理解这一点至关重要，不是吗？纳粹正在……所以霍斯特·威塞尔被戈培尔派去殴打共产党人、挑衅他们，并激起针对他们的街头斗殴。因此，对霍斯特·威塞尔和戈培尔来说，共产党人是主要的敌人。但对共产党人来说，尽管他们不喜欢纳粹，如果有机会，他们也会走到威塞尔的房间里朝他的脸开枪。
But for them, in a way, the main enemy aren't the Nazis at all. It's the Social Democrats. Yeah, it's a funny one, isn't it? It's kind of like people on the far left of the labour party disliking blairites more than they dislike tories it is that it is that in a way tom i mean it's a very sort of exaggerated lurid version of that so the yes i think the communists would say they'd say the nazis are just a kind of efflorescence. The Nazis are just clowns and criminals. The real enemy are the bourgeois capitalists of the SPD and their allies, the liberals, the Catholic Centre Party. These are
但对他们来说，在某种程度上，主要的敌人根本不是纳粹。而是社会民主党。是的，这很有趣，不是吗？这有点像工党极左翼的人比讨厌保守党人更讨厌布莱尔派一样。确实如此，确实如此，汤姆。我的意思是，这是那种现象的一个非常夸张、耸人听闻的版本。所以，是的，我想共产党人会说，他们会说纳粹只是一种暂时的繁荣，
the people who are holding us down. These are the people for whom the police work and all this kind of thing. And they're the people we must smash to build a worker's state. Yeah. And this is a tension that kind of goes back to Rosa Luxemburg and everybody who, her death in 1919, the communists blame on the Social Democrats, but presumably gets turbocharged by the experience of the Depression. It does indeed.
纳粹只是小丑和罪犯。真正的敌人是社会民主党的资产阶级资本主义者以及他们的盟友——自由党、天主教中央党。这些人才是压迫我们的人。这些人才是警察为之效力的对象，诸如此类。这些人才是我们为了建立工人国家必须粉碎的人。是的。这种紧张关系可以追溯到罗莎·卢森堡及所有人，她在1919年的死，共产党人归咎于社会民主党，但这大概在大萧条的经历中得到了极大加剧。确实如此。
Absolutely does. So 1929, in May 1929, there's a very famous incident shown in the series Babylon Berlin called Bloody May May where the Berlin police who are being controlled by the social democrats they attack a communist demonstration they kill 33 people and injure hundreds more I mean this for the communists is you know this inflames them against the social democrats still further now of course the interesting thing is
绝对是这样。因此，在1929年5月，发生了一起非常有名的事件，在《巴比伦柏林》剧集中也有展示，被称为“流血五月”（Bloody May Day）。当时由社会民主党控制的柏林警察袭击了一场共产主义示威活动，杀害了33人，并打伤了数百人。我的意思是，对共产党人来说，这进一步激起了他们对社会民主党的仇恨。现在，当然，有趣的是，
the communists hate the bourgeois parties as much as they hate the Nazis. The bourgeois parties are the people who vote for them. If they are given a choice, if they had to choose between the stalinism they look at the nazis they say well the nazis probably they talk very you know they're full of all this stuff and all this violence but actually if they got into government they'll probably tell you they won't nick your house they won't they won't confiscate your property and probably they would work with conservative elites and it would actually all be fine so and so the the effect of this uh a great great sentence in michael burley's book third reich new history um the electoral profile of the national socialist party has been described as an integrative people's party with an accentuated middle-class character or less pretentiously as having the profile of a man with a pot belly
共产党人痛恨资产阶级政党的程度不亚于他们痛恨纳粹。资产阶级政党正是那些投票支持他们的人。如果让他们选择，如果必须在斯大林主义……他们看着纳粹，心想：好吧，纳粹可能——他们说的话非常……他们充满了这一切和所有这些暴力，但实际上，如果他们进入政府，他们可能会告诉你，他们不会抢你的房子，他们不会没收你的财产，而且他们可能会与保守派精英合作，实际上这一切都会好起来的。因此，迈克尔·伯利（Michael Burley）的著作《第三帝国新史》（Third Reich: A New History）中有一句非常棒的话：民族社会主义党的选举形象被描述为一个“具有突出的中产阶级特质的整合型人民党”，或者用更不那么矫饰的话说，拥有“一个大腹便便的男人的形象”。
well yeah that's absolutely mean, it's definitely true that even though you have the antics of people like Horse Vessel being shot in the face and street fighting, that by 1929, 1930 or so, the Nazis are beginning to win more kind of respectable votes. Now, all of that said, the Nazis still would not have got into power i think had it not been for the fact that the weimar elites commit probably the most flagrant and shocking act of political suicide in modern history and what will follow is very complicated and intricate and involves all kinds of maneuvering and faction fighting but step by the people who should, as we said last time, the people who should be the guardians of Weimar democracy are actually digging its grave and indeed their own
嗯，是的，这绝对是——我的意思是，这绝对是真的。尽管有像霍斯特·威塞尔被枪击面部以及街头斗殴这样的闹剧，但到1929年、1930年前后，纳粹开始赢得更多体面的选票。尽管如此，如果不是因为魏玛精英们犯下了现代历史上最公然、最令人震惊的政治自杀行为，纳粹依然无法掌权。接下来的事情非常复杂繁复，涉及各种政治手腕和派系斗争，但那些本该——正如我们上次所说——本该成为魏玛民主守护者的人，实际上却在为它挖掘坟墓，在某些情况下，也是在为他们自己
graves in some circumstances. So should we get into that story, Tom? It's a complicated story. Are you girding your loins? Yeah, let's gird our loins for this. So the process by which the Weimar Republic commits suicide against this backdrop of depression, of street fighting, of red on brown violence and brown on red violence. So terrible situation when really anyone with a concern for democracy should be manning the defences. And instead, they basically kind of demolished the walls they do so the first blow is struck in march 1930 so up to this point the government had been run by a grand coalition under a guy called herman muller who was the um who's from the social democrats and it's a coalition of the social democrats the liberal parties and the catholic center party but that
挖掘坟墓。那么，我们应该讲讲那个故事吗，汤姆？这是一个复杂的故事。你在系紧腰带吗？是的，让我们为此系紧腰带吧。所以，在萧条、街头斗殴、红褐暴力交织的背景下，魏玛共和国自取灭亡的过程。这是一个可怕的局面，任何关心民主的人本该都在坚守防线。然而相反，他们基本上拆毁了防御工事。他们确实这样做了。第一击是在1930年3月发出的。在此之前，政府一直由一个大联合政府运转，领导人是赫尔曼·穆勒（Hermann Müller），他是社会民主党人，
for various complicated reasons which we don't need to go into that coalition falls apart and at that point there was no majority in the reichstag now president hindenburg the world war one general who we talked about last time who is the prussian walrus the prussian walrus as you described him i said he was he was cut from oak but you described as a walrus he's both he's an oak wooden walrus. He and his circle have never liked democracy, never liked all the parliamentary horse trading. They distrust it.
这是一个由社会民主党、自由党和天主教中央党组成的联盟。但由于各种我们不必细究的复杂原因，这个联合联盟破裂了。当时，国会中已经没有多数派了。现在，总统兴登堡——我们在上期节目中谈到的那位一战将军，普鲁士海象——你形容他为普鲁士海象——我说他是用橡木雕成的，但你形容他是海象——他两者皆是。他是一头橡木制的海象。他和他的核心圈子从不喜欢民主，从不喜欢所有议会的政治交易。他们对此深表怀疑。
They think it's un-German. They think it's weak. They think it betrays the legacy of Bismarck and the Kaiser. And they think this is a good chance to start building, you know, the road towards the return of a proper authoritarian regime. And the people in the army like this, they think, yes, because we want to rearm. We hate the Treaty of Versailles.
他们认为这很不德国。他们认为这很软弱。他们认为这背叛了俾斯麦和德皇的遗绪。他们认为这是一个开始建立——你知道的——通往恢复正统威权政体道路的好机会。军队里的人也喜欢这样，他们心想：太好了，因为我们需要重新武装。我们痛恨《凡尔赛条约》。
We hate having to answer to politicians. The more we can sort of facilitate this, the better. So Hindenburg and the army generals around him, they agree that basically the answer is stop subordinating everything to parliamentary politics. Let's have a cabinet of experts. You pick a guy from the Reichstag, and they will rule by emergency decree. So this is the one that right from the beginning had been used. Yeah, that Ebert, the Social Democrat, had used it against the left in the early 20s. It's this sort of ticking time bomb in the Weimar constitution. I guess probably a lot of constitutions have similar emergency provisions, but the Germans have been getting used, they've got addicted to using this.
我们痛恨必须向政治家负责。我们能为此推波助澜得越多越好。因此，兴登堡和他周围的陆军将军们一致认为，基本上解决的办法是停止将一切服从于议会政治。让我们组建一个专家内阁。你从国会中挑选一个人，让他们通过紧急法令进行统治。所以这就是那个从一开始就被——是的。爱伯特这位社会民主党人在20世纪20年代初曾对左翼使用过它。这是魏玛宪法中一颗定时炸弹。我想大概很多宪法都有类似的紧急条款，但德国人已经习惯了，他们对使用这一条款上了瘾。
Hindenburg thinks we'll rule by decree. We won't need to worry about parliamentary majorities. So he brings in a chap from the Catholic centre party, the Zentrum, whose name is Heinrich Brüning. Brüning is from Munster. He's from a very devout Catholic family. He's a very, very clever man. He's very austere, kind of bald-haired, glasses. He'd studied, interestingly, Strasbourg, Bonn, and the London School of Economics, Tom. And his thesis, his PhD thesis was on British railways. So clearly, clearly Germany was doomed then. So yes. So he, yet another Iron Cross winner in World War I,
兴登堡认为我们可以通过法令统治。我们不必担心国会的多数派。因此，他引入了天主教中央党（Zentrum）的一个家伙，名叫海因里希·布吕宁（Heinrich Brüning）。布吕宁来自明斯特。他出身于一个非常虔诚的天主教家庭。他是一个非常非常聪明的人。他非常严厉，有些秃顶，戴着眼镜。有趣的是，汤姆，他曾在斯特拉斯堡、波恩和伦敦政治经济学院学习过。他的博士论文是关于英国铁路的。很显然，德国那时显然已经注定要灭亡了。所以，是的。他也是一位在一战中获得过铁十字勋章的人，
very patriotic, a monarchist, a believer in the Kaiser, a sort of small C conservative man, very, very serious Catholic, a tax specialist. He's got a bit of, associated with the rest of his history, Antonio Salazar. Ah, yes. About him, I think it's fair to say. In fact, there's a couple of Salazarist kind of characters in this.
非常爱国，保皇派，德皇的信奉者，一个带有小c保守主义色彩的人，非常非常严肃的天主教徒，税收专家。我觉得公平地说，他身上有点像我们在《历史其余》中谈到过的安东尼奥·萨拉查（Antonio Salazar）的影子。啊，是的。关于他，我觉得这样说并不过分。事实上，这里面有几个带有萨拉查色彩的人物。
So he's very reactionary, in other words. He is pretty reactionary. His party is normally the centre party, but he's pretty much on the right of that party. It's been moving to the right anyway. And he... I mean, is he as kind of, you know, back to 1450 as Salazar?
换句话说，他非常反动。他相当反动。他的党派通常是中央党，但他基本上处于该党右翼。反正该党也一直在向右转。而且他——我的意思是，他有像萨拉查那样——你知道的——回到1450年那种程度的反动吗？
No, he's not. He's not quite that bad. No, he's not quite that bad at all. But he is austere. His instincts are quite authoritarian. So he starts, he restricts the freedom of the press quite early on. His economic policy is very deflationary. So what that means is... When you say he restricts the freedom of the press quite early on. His economic policy is very deflationary.
不，他不是。他没那么糟糕。不，他绝对没那么糟糕。但他很严苛。他的本能相当专制。所以他很早就开始限制新闻自由。他的经济政策非常具有通货紧缩性质。这意味着……当你说他很早就开始限制新闻自由，他的经济政策非常具有通货紧缩性质时……
So what that means is- When you say he restricts the press, is he restricting just the left-wing press or all the press? Yes, yes. So all of Bruning's kind of law and order measures and things, they tend to be directed more at the left than the right. And this is that fear of communism thing. This underestimation of the Nazis and the belief,
这意味着——当你讲他限制新闻时，他是在仅仅限制左翼报纸还是所有的报纸？是的，是的。所以布吕宁的所有法律与秩序措施之类的事情，往往更多针对左翼而非右翼。这就是对共产主义的恐惧作祟。这种对纳粹的低估，以及一种在你可以称之为体面的议会政党中非常普遍的信念，
very common among what you might call the respectable parliamentary parties, that the real threat is communism. You can understand why they think that, Tom. They want to protect their property and the class system and all of that stuff. They're also looking at what's happened in the Soviet Union. They think, Christ, that's the last thing we want to happen here. So this is understandable but fatal. Bruning's economic policy is very deflationary. He doesn't believe in tax and spend. He doesn't believe in what we'd now call Keynesianism,
即真正的威胁是共产主义。你可以理解他们为什么这么想，汤姆。他们想要保护自己的财产、阶级制度以及所有这些东西。他们也在看着苏联发生的事情。他们心想：“天哪，这绝对是我们最不想在这里发生的事。”所以这虽可以理解，但却是致命的。布吕宁的经济政策非常具有紧缩性。他不相信税收与开支。他不相信我们现在所说的主义，
so public works, all of that stuff. He says, listen, in the midst of the Depression, the thing to do is batten down the hatches, stabilize your economy, cut spending. Incidentally, this is exactly what the British are doing. So are Ramsey MacDonald and Stanley Baldwin. So this is not unheard of by any means. It's kind of what Herbert Hoover was doing in the United States.
比如公共工程等等。他说：“听着，在大萧条时期，要做的事是紧闭舱门，稳定经济，削减开支。”顺便说一句，这正是英国人正在做的。拉姆齐·麦克唐纳（Ramsey MacDonald）和斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）也是这么做的。所以这绝非闻所未闻。这基本上就是赫伯特·胡佛（Herbert Hoover）在美国所做的事情。
Let's not print money. We've learned the lesson of printing money in the hyperinflation, so that's the last thing we do. The result of this is he cuts lots of people's unemployment benefits, pushes lots more people into poverty, makes himself the most unpopular chancellor since the beginning of the Weimar Republic. So this is very Herbert Hoover. Very Herbert Hoover. Exactly what's happening in the United States at the same time. Pretty much what actually happens in Britain under Ramsay MacDonald that splits the Labour Party. So you can sort of see how we were talking so much
让我们不要印钞票。我们已经吸取了恶性通货膨胀中印钞票的教训，所以这是我们最不会做的事。这导致的结果是，他削减了许多人的失业救济金，将更多的人推入贫困，使自己成为魏玛共和国成立以来最不受欢迎的宰相。所以这非常像赫伯特·胡佛。非常像赫伯特·胡佛。这几乎就是英国在拉姆齐·麦克唐纳领导下导致工党分裂的真实写照。所以你可以看出，我们之前谈了那么多，
about how much this story is unique to Germany. There are so many shared elements, but because it's happening in Germany with the street violence, with this traumatised, embittered population, it all just takes on a different character. And the framework of democracy starting to creak under the pressure.
关于这个故事在多大程度上是德国独有的。其实有那么多共同的元素，但由于它发生在德国，伴随着街头暴力、饱受创伤且充满怨恨的人口，这一切呈现出了一种截然不同的特质。而且民主的框架在压力下开始吱呀作响。
Starting to crumble. Yeah. Brüning decides he's going to ask kindenberg in the autumn of 1930 to dissolve the reichstag and to call an election ian kershaw calls this a decision of breathtaking irresponsibility not the last that will be made in this podcast so because bruning thinks you know what bruning thinks the german people will never vote for these clowns, the Nazis. And, you know, hopefully I can get some kind of cobble together, some kind of coalition. And he also thinks, in the worst comes to the worst, Hindenburg will always protect the constitution. That's what he's sworn to do. He's a dutiful Prussian officer. He wouldn't do anything
开始崩溃。是的。布吕宁决定在1930年秋天请求兴登堡解散国会并举行大选。伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）称这是一个“令人窒息的不负责任的决定”——当然，这不会是这期播客中做出的最后一个此类决定。因为布吕宁认为——你知道的，布吕宁认为德国人民绝不会投票给纳粹这些小丑。并且，你知道，希望我能拼凑出一个某种形式的联合政府。他也认为，最坏的情况下，兴登堡总是会保护宪法。那是他发誓要做的。他是一个恪尽职守的普鲁士军官。他不会做任何
stupid. Again, a terrible miscalculation. So we're plunged into an election campaign. You talked about a horse vessel being shot at the beginning of 1930 throughout 90 and the funeral and goebbels's speech throughout 1930 the nazis have basically whipped themselves into this frenzy marches parades because that's what that's what goebbels is famous for and he's you know horse vessels funeral exemplifies that that they're very very good at making a show putting on a show and in the context of this bleakness unemployment people with nothing to do a party that puts on a show and is promising national renewal you can you know you can see presumably any kind of detailed policy. No detailed. So it's the classic populist party program.
愚蠢的事。同样，这是一个糟糕至极的误判。于是我们陷入了一场选举战。你谈到了1930年初霍斯特·威塞尔被枪击，以及整个1930年期间的葬礼和戈培尔的演讲。整个1930年期间，纳粹基本上把自己煽动成了一种狂热状态，游行、集市——因为这就是戈培尔闻名遐迩的地方，而威塞尔的葬礼就是最好的例证——他们非常非常擅长摆场面、举行游行。而在这种阴暗萧条、失业率高企、人们无所事事的背景下，一个大肆摆场面并承诺国家复兴的政党，你可以——你知道的——大概可以想见任何详细的政策都无需存在。没有细节。所以这就是标准的民粹主义政党纲领。
Something for everybody. No specifics. Cake all round. They slyly downplay. So the anti-Semitism never goes away. But the key thing in the autumn of 1930 is they say, it's the system that has failed you. The system has let you down.
人人有份。没有具体细节。人人有蛋糕吃。他们狡猾地淡化了这一点。所以反犹太主义从未消失。但1930年秋天的关键点在于他们说：“是体制辜负了你们。是体制让你们失望了。”
The established politicians, what a waste of space they are. They have betrayed you ever since 1918. And what we offer is an end to class politics. The communists are giving you class politics. We'll end that. We're all Germans. We don't even see the classes. National unity, a racial community united and working together for greatness. They have sort of films, they have brass bands, they have parades pumping this stuff out. And clearly a lot of people, it's what they want to hear. So you have the election results.
那些老牌政客，他们是多么的无用啊。自从1918年以来，他们就背叛了你们。而我们所提供的是对阶级政治的终结。共产党人给你们带来的是阶级政治。我们将结束这一切。我们全都是德国人。我们甚至不分阶层。民族团结，一个紧密团结、为伟大而共同奋斗的种族共同体。他们通过电影、铜管乐队、游行来宣传这些东西。显然，很多人这正是他们想听到的。于是就有了选举结果。
They are a terrible blow to the Weimar system. It's not because the Social Democrats or the Catholic Centre Party lose votes. They're pretty much where they were. It's that the established mainstream, respectable, conservative parties. The bourgeois parties. The bourgeois parties. The kind of parties that you wouldn't vote for in a depression because they're the parties of the rich of the upper middle classes. They are just pretty much annihilated.
这对魏玛体制是一个沉重的打击。这不是因为社会民主党或天主教中央党失去了选票。他们的得票情况和以前差不多。而是那些老牌主流、体面、保守的政党——资产阶级政党——
The communists go up from 54 seats to 77 seats, but the big, big winners are the Nazis. Up from a million votes last time, fringe party. They're now on six and a half million. They're up from 12 seats to 107 seats. And if you look at the kind of people who voted for them, we talked last time about how they'd started to expand among kind of Protestant farmers,
资产阶级政党。这类政党你在大萧条时期是不会投票给它们的，因为它们是富人和上中产阶级的政党。它们几乎被彻底消灭了。
people in North Germany, in Schleswig-Holstein, in Pomerania, in Hanover, and all these kind of provincial kind of places. They're now beginning to win many more kind of respectable sort of Michael Burley's potbelly symbols. So teachers, Protestant priests, people who see them as an antidote to communism. So they're a social protest party. They also, crucially, and this is again a nice nod to your
共产党人的席位从54席增加到77席，但最大、最大的赢家是纳粹党。他们的得票从上次的一百万票、一个边缘小党，一跃达到了六百五十万票。他们的席位从12席飙升至107席。如果你看看投票给他们的人群，我们上次谈到他们如何开始在北德、石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因、波美拉尼亚、汉诺威以及所有这些地方的新教农民中扩张。他们现在开始赢得更多体面的——迈克尔·伯利笔下的大腹便便的象征——也就是教师、新教牧师，那些将他们视为共产主义解毒剂的人。所以他们是一个社会抗议政党。此外，至关重要的是——这也是对你介绍霍斯特·威塞尔的一个很好的呼应——年轻人，年轻人，首次投票的年轻选民。
horse vessel introduction, youngsters, young people, young first-time voters. So one in four Nazi voters in 1930 have never voted before. So anybody who thinks, oh, young people have a predisposition to be left wing. I mean, this is an absolute kind of rebuke to that. So this is a terrible, terrible result for Weimar. You've got many more, you have 77 communists who hate the Weimar Republic sitting in the Reichstag, and you have 107 national socialists. And the only bigger party than that are the social democrats themselves. It's not just that you've had all this sort of street violence. It's that actually, the language and the tone of the street violence is now in the
因此，1930年四分之一的纳粹选民此前从未投过票。所以任何认为“哦，年轻人倾向于左翼”的人——我的意思是，这绝对是对这种说法的狠狠反驳。所以这对魏玛来说是一个可怕、可怕的结果。你有整整77名痛恨魏玛共和国的共产党人坐在国会里，还有107名民族社会主义者。而比他们更大的党派只有社会民主党自己。这不仅仅是因为发生了所有这些街头暴力。而是实际上，街头暴力的语言和基调现在已经进入了
central arena of politics. So the Reichstag itself, instead of being all these sort of men who basically all look the same, grey men in kind of- In frock coats. In frock coats and sort of excessively tight collars. It's now, there's a lot of shouting and shaking of fists and- And uniforms. People calling each other vermin, all of that sort of stuff, exactly. And that dual strategy the Nazis have been adopting of the ballot box and the street
政治的核心舞台。因此，国会本身，不再是一群基本上长相完全一致的人——穿着晨礼服、打着过紧领子的灰色男人——
violence are now eligning, essentially. Exactly. So the violence has been imported into the heart of the Weimar Republic, the Weimar system. Exactly right. And the Weimar system at this point, I think you could argue, is it dead at this point? Whether Weimar itself is dead is an interesting question, but I think it is definitely seriously ailing. And as we will see after the break, what makes things worse is the politicians continue to make extremely bad
而是充满了叫喊、挥舞拳头以及——身穿制服的人。人们互相称对方为害虫，诸如此类的东西，完全如此。纳粹一直采取的投票箱与街头暴力双轨战略，现在基本上合流了。
decisions and bad choices that basically condemn the patient to a swift and pretty miserable death. So join us after the break for the death of Weimar. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
完全正确。所以暴力已经被输入到了魏玛共和国、魏玛体制的核心。完全正确。而此时的魏玛体制，我认为你可以说，它此时已经死了吗？魏玛本身是否已经死亡是一个有趣的问题，但我认为它无疑已经病入膏荒。正如我们在中场休息后将要看到的，使情况变得更糟的是，政客们继续做出极其糟糕的决定和糟糕的选择，这些选择基本上宣告了这位病人的迅速且相当悲惨的死亡。请在休息后与我们一起收看魏玛的覆灭。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We promised you before the break the death of Weimar. And Dominic, I mean, there's a terrible, tragic sense in which kind of Weimar dies of the very political complications with which it's been wrestling throughout its existence. The Nazis don't storm to power wielding guns or marching on the Capitol or anything like that. They do it by means of backroom deals, election gambits, all the kinds of things that we would recognize from a functioning democracy, but they're doing it with the aim of terminating democracy. And this is the issue with which in the 21st century, certainly the 2010s and 2020s, people have started to wrestle, isn't it? What do you do in a democracy with somebody who is competing, who is playing as a contestant, but is determined to destroy the very game in which they are playing. How do you exclude them? How do you control them? Do you try to tame them? Do you work with them?
你好，欢迎回到《历史其余》。我们在中场休息前向大家承诺过要讲述魏玛的覆灭。多米尼克，我的意思是，有一种可怕而悲剧的感觉，即魏玛在某种程度上死于它在其整个生存期间一直在与之搏斗的政治复杂性之中。纳粹并不是挥舞着枪支、冲进国会大厦或类似的事情来夺取政权的。他们是通过幕后交易、选举策略——所有这些我们从一个运转良好的民主国家中所能认同的方式来实现这一点的，但他们这样做的目的是为了终结民主。这就是在21世纪，特别是2010年代和2020年代，人们开始纠结的问题，不是吗？你在民主国家中，该如何对待一个作为竞争者、作为参赛者，却决心摧毁他所参与的游戏本身的人？你该如何将他们排除在外？你该如何控制他们？你是否试图驯服他们？你是否与他们合作？
Would you just say never? So this is the problem that is facing the, and of course, for the Weimar parliamentarians, they have no precedent. You know, there is no... Right. Yes. So for us, this is the paradigmatic political morality story, but they don't have that morality story. I mean, I suppose any morality story they would have would be the end of the Roman Republic, something like that. But I don't think people are making that comparison, actually. Well, some are. So the Roman Revolution, the famous book by Syme about the collapse of the Roman Republic is being written against exactly this backdrop. Yes, that's a very good point, Tom. So I think people are kind of vaguely aware of it, but obviously it's inadequate to compare to the moral horror for us.
还是你会直截了当地说“绝不”？所以，这是摆在……当然，对于魏玛的议会主义者来说，他们没有先例。你知道，没有……对的，是的。所以对我们来说，这是一个典型的政治道德故事，但他们并没有那个道德故事。我的意思是，我想他们可能有的任何道德故事大概就是罗马共和国的灭亡之类的事。但我认为人们当时并没有做出这种比较。嗯，有些人有。所以，罗马革命，萨因（Syme）关于罗马共和国崩溃的名著，正是在这种背景下撰写的。是的，这是一个非常好的观点，汤姆。所以我想人们对此有模糊的意识，但很显然，这无法与我们所感受到的道德恐怖相提并论。
So, yeah, I mean, I think that is always a really important thing to bear in mind when looking at this story, is that we have the example of the Nazi takeover, but people living through the Nazi takeover obviously didn't. Yeah, so almost none of the characters that we're going to meet in the second half take the Nazis seriously. They just don't see. They maybe haven't read Mein Kampf. They see them as violent clowns who they can use. So Chancellor Heinrich Brüning, the sort of austere Catholic British Railways enthusiast who we talked about in the first half he has now has no real chance of a majority in fact there is no majority for anything at all
所以，是的，我认为在审视这个故事时，始终牢记这一点非常重要，那就是我们拥有纳粹接管政权的例子，但亲历纳粹接管政权的人显然没有。是的，所以我们在下半场将遇到的几乎所有角色都没有把纳粹当回事。他们根本看不到。他们或许没有读过《我的奋斗》。他们把纳粹看作是可以利用的暴力小丑。因此，宰相海因里希·布吕宁——我们在上半场谈到的那个严厉的天主教英国铁路迷——现在在国会中实际上已经没有获得多数派的真实机会了。事实上，根本没有任何事情能获得多数支持。
in the reichstag from september 1930 onwards so increasingly in the next few years you see endlessly being suspended or adjourned or when it does meet just a lot of shouting and and um sort of disputation and so how is the country being governed so it's being governed by decree bruning is governing it by decree using hindenburg so basically the And so how is the country being governed? So it's being governed by decree. Brüning is governing it by decree using Hindenburg. So basically the way that works is the Reich Chancellor, which is Brüning, goes to President Hindenburg and says, under Article 48, I would like you to do this. And Hindenburg basically says yes. And who is kind of holding the strings of who? Well, this is always a little bit unclear. Everybody is trying to pull the strings of
从1930年9月起，在帝国议会中，所以在接下来的几年里，你会看到它不断地被暂停、休会，或者当它确实开会时，也只是充斥着大量的叫喊和呃某种争论，那么国家是如何被治理的呢？它是通过法令来治理的，布吕宁正在通过法令利用兴登堡来治理它，所以基本上
everybody else. And here there's a really interesting character enters the story. So there's a rising figure who's a kind of intermediary between politics and the army. And this is a chap called General Kurt von Schleicher. He's a Prussian, you'll be surprised to hear, born in 1882. He's clever. He's a great intriguer. Everybody knows that Schleicher loves intrigue. He's always sort of whispering in back rooms. He's a very political general. He's worked his way up the ladder. I read in the Bodleian Library, Tom, it says,
每个人。而这里有一个非常有趣的角色走进了故事。所以有一个正在崛起的人物，他是政界和军队之间的一种中间人。这是一个名叫库尔特·冯·施莱谢尔将军的家伙。他是普鲁士人，你听到可能会很惊讶，出生于1882年。他很聪明。他是一个超级阴谋家。大家都知道施莱谢尔喜欢阴谋。他总是在后室里窃窃私语。他是一个非常政治化的将军。他一步步爬上了高位。我在博德利图书馆读到过，汤姆，上面写着
Schleicher was well known for his sense of humor, his lively conversational skills, his sharp wit, and his habit of abandoning his upper-class aristocratic accent to speak his German with a salty, working-class Berlin accent full of risque phrases that many found either charming or vulgar. So I read that on Wikipedia, so it's almost certainly not true. But it's a nice pen portrait, isn't it? It's a nice pen portrait.
施莱谢尔以其幽默感、生动的对话技巧、犀利的机智而闻名，他还有一种习惯，就是丢掉上流社会的贵族口音，用带有粗俗的柏林工人阶级口音说德语，里面夹杂着许多打擦边球的短语，许多人觉得这些短语要么迷人，要么粗俗。所以我是在维基百科上读到这一点的，所以它几乎肯定不是真的。但这是一个很好的生动写照，不是吗？这是一个很好的生动写照。
Trotsky, of all people, said Schleicher was a question mark with the epaulettes of a general. That's a very good quote. He's a Prussian general who's just scheming the whole time. Too clever by half. But everybody knows it. This is the trouble. Yeah.
托洛茨基偏偏说，施莱谢尔是一个戴着将军肩章的问号。这真是一句绝妙的名言。他是一个普鲁士将军，整天都在密谋。聪明过头了。但大家都知道这一点。这就是麻烦所在。是的。
What he seems to want is a military dictatorship of some kind, an authoritarian vehicle. And he is playing off Hindenburg, the politicians. He's talking to the Nazis quite early on. Presumably the example of Bismarck is hanging over this. I suppose he might see himself as a bit of a Bismarck. I mean, what the army wants is they want a government that will basically,
他似乎想要的是某种形式的军事独裁，一种独裁工具。他在兴登堡和政客之间玩弄平衡。他很早就开始与纳粹对话了。大概俾斯麦的榜样一直萦绕在脑海中。我想他可能把自己看作是一个小俾斯麦。我的意思是，军队想要的是一个基本上
they won't be bothered by politicians anymore. They'll be able to rearm and make Germany great again. Yeah, yeah, get out the tanks. And that probably will involve wars. But I don't think people in the army think, let's wage a massive world war and take on all the old allies again for round two. They think, let's fight the Poles and get Danzig.
他们不会再被政客们打扰。他们将能够重新武装并让德国再次伟大。是的，是的，把坦克开出来。这可能涉及战争。但我认为军队里的人不会想，让我们发动一场大规模的世界大战，再次与所有老盟友进行第二回合。他们想的是，去跟波兰人打一仗，拿下但泽。
Have a crack at the Czechs. Exactly. And we'll feel good about ourselves. I think that's what they're after. Now, President Hindenburg is 84. His presidential term is up in 1932. He toys with standing down, but such is the sort of chaos and confusion at the time that it's fairly easy for his advisor to persuade him to stand again. So now we have this crazy situation where Hindenburg,
顺便收拾一下捷克人。没错。然后我们会自我感觉良好。我想这正是他们所追求的。现在，兴登堡总统已经84岁了。他的总统任期将于1932年结束。他曾考虑过退位，但当时的混乱和迷茫使得他的顾问很容易说服他再次参选。所以现在我们面临着这样一种疯狂的情况：兴登堡
the epitome of the Prussian reactionary, is standing again for the presidency. And his two big rivals in the second round, so the first round is sort of ambiguous, so this goes to a second round. His two big rivals are Tellmann, the leader of the communists, and Hitler, the leader of the Nazis. So what that means, it's a bit like a supercharged version of those kind of Macron-Le Pen or Chirac-Le Pen elections, where loads of people who normally would hate the
这个普鲁士反动派的化身，正在再次竞选总统。他在第二轮选举中的两个主要竞争对手——第一轮有些模糊不清，所以进入了第二轮——他的两个主要竞争对手是共产党领袖台尔曼和纳粹党领袖希特勒。所以这意味着，这有点像马克龙与勒庞或希拉克与勒庞那种选举的超级强化版，大量通常会讨厌
mainstream person have to hold their nose and vote for them because they can't stand the extremist alternatives. Because Hindenburg, who hates Weimar, is now the candidate for Weimar. Exactly right. Yeah, exactly. The Social Democrats, they describe him as the embodiment of calm and constancy, of manly loyalty and devotion to duty, a man on whose work one can build, a man of pure desire and serene judgment. I mean, that's a bonkers thing to say because Hindenburg thinks the Social Democrats
主流人物的人不得不捏着鼻子投票给他们，因为他们无法忍受极端主义的替代方案。因为痛恨魏玛的兴登堡，现在成了魏玛的候选人。完全正确。是的，完全正确。社会民主党人将他描述为平静与坚定、男子汉般的忠诚和对职责的奉献的化身，一个其工作值得信赖的人，一个有着纯洁愿望和清醒判断力的人。我的意思是，说出这样的话简直是疯了，因为兴登堡认为社会民主党人
are absolute, you know. And they know it. Yeah, he holds them in very low regard. So it goes to a second ballot. And for the first time, Hitler, the Nazis import American style campaign techniques. So this is where he gets on planes, doesn't he? He gets on a plane. For the first time, yeah.
绝对是，你知道的。而且他们也心知肚明。是的，他非常看不起他们。因此选举进入了第二轮投票。希特勒和纳粹党人破天荒地引入了美国式的竞选技巧。所以这就是他坐上飞机的时候，对吧？他坐上了飞机。破天荒地，是的。
And this is the interesting thing, isn't it, about the Nazis, about fascism generally, how it's simultaneously backward looking and incredibly futuristic. So same with Mussolini. Love his planes and cars and things. Men of thing. People are very, very excited by this. They're very good at democracy. That's the weird thing. That's the irony of it.
这就是关于纳粹、关于一般法西斯主义的有趣之处，不是吗？它如何能够同时兼顾怀旧和极其超前。所以墨索里尼也是如此。喜欢他的飞机、汽车之类的东西。崇尚实干的人。人们对此感到非常非常兴奋。他们非常擅长民主。这就是奇怪的地方。这就是它的讽刺之处。
They're deploying all kinds of tricks and techniques that are still being deployed to this day. Yeah, I guess that's true. I mean, as we said last time, if you watch Leni Riefenstahl, Triumph of the Will, you watch Nazi rallies, do political party conferences in Britain or American presidential conventions in the United States, do they learn those techniques? Of course they do. They absolutely do.
他们正在部署各种至今仍在使用的小把戏和技巧。是的，我想这是真的。我的意思是，正如我们上次所说，如果你观看莱妮·里芬施塔尔的《意志的胜利》，如果你观看纳粹集会，去看看英国的政党代表大会或美国总统候选人提名大会，他们是从中学习了这些技巧吗？他们当然学了。他们绝对学了。
So Hitler gets 37% in that presidential election, 13 million votes. Hindenburg gets 53%. That's actually pretty weak by Hindenburg, given he is the titanic war hero, and he's got almost all the conventional parties behind him. And actually, in some parts of the Protestant countryside, Schleswig-Holstein, Pomerania, Hitler actually wins. Hitler beats Hindenburg. Such is the sense of anger about the depression and desperation for something new. So it's pretty clear that the wind is in the Nazis' sails.
因此，希特勒在那次总统选举中获得了37%的选票，即1300万张选票。兴登堡获得了53%。鉴于兴登堡是泰坦级的战争英雄，而且他背后几乎拥有所有传统政党，这个成绩其实相当弱。事实上，在石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因和波美拉尼亚的一些新教农村地区，希特勒实际上赢了。希特勒击败了兴登堡。人们对大萧条的愤怒以及对新事物的渴望已经达到了这种程度。所以很明显，纳粹正顺风顺水。
And actually Brüning, who's still hanging around, who's been, I think it's fair, I don't actually, Richard Evans, for example, is very harsh on Brüning. He just regards Brüning as an absolute waste of space. I think that's a tiny bit harsh, but it's fair to say Brüning has made a series of very bad decisions. He basically gets booted out at the end of May 1932. So now Hindenburg needs a new chancellor. He's not going to pick Hitler. Hitler's an extremist, a rabble-rouser, a demagogue, a mere corporal.
事实上，布吕宁仍然在周围晃荡，他一直被——我认为这样说是公平的，其实理查德·埃文斯对布吕宁就非常严厉。他简直把布吕宁视为彻头彻尾的废物。我认为这有点过于严厉了，但可以说布吕宁做出了一系列非常糟糕的决定。他在1932年5月底基本上被踢出去了。所以现在兴登堡需要一位新总理。他不会选择希特勒。希特勒是个极端分子、煽动家、蛊惑人心的政客、区区下士。
He's not going to pick Hitler. He picks a man, the ultimate sort of establishment man, and this is a chap called Franz von Papen. Well, you've got a brilliant description in your notes. Looks like a greyhound or a man from the Daily Telegraph. Yeah, there's people listening from the Daily Telegraph. I don't know, do they like a greyhound or a man from the daily telegraph yeah there's people listening from the daily telegraph i don't know do they look like greyhounds maybe they do well you're thinking of charles moore someone like that yeah i actually you know kind of the tall thin angular do you know the columnist tim stanley yes i knew tim stanley when he was a very
他不会选择希特勒。他选择了一个人，可以说是体制内最典型的人物，这个家伙名叫弗朗茨·冯·帕彭。好吧，你在笔记里有一个精彩的描述。看起来像是一条灵缇犬或者《每日电讯报》的人。是的，有来自《每日电讯报》的人在听节目。我不知道，他们喜欢灵缇犬还是《每日电讯报》的人呢？是的，有来自《每日电讯报》的人在听。我不知道，他们看起来像灵缇犬吗？也许是的。好吧，你想到的是查尔斯·穆尔这样的人。是的，我实际上，你知道的，那种又高又瘦有棱有角的，你知道专栏作家蒂姆·斯坦利吗？是的，我认识蒂姆·斯坦利，当他还是一个非常
young man uh i think franz von papen looks an older, more Germanic version of Tim Stanley. Tim Stanley has quite vibrant hair. Yeah, bouffant, I would say. Bouffant hair. Does Franz von Papen? No, but there's something in the features. I can't really describe it. Listen, I mean, this is of no use to most people who don't know who these people are.
年轻人的时候，呃，我觉得弗朗茨·冯·帕彭看起来像是蒂姆·斯坦利年长、更具日耳曼风的版本。蒂姆·斯坦利的头发相当有活力。是的，蓬松的发型，我会这么说。蓬松的头发。弗朗茨·冯·帕彭也是吗？不，但他的五官有某种相似之处。我真的无法形容。听着，我的意思是，这对大多数不认识这些人的听众来说毫无用处。
But anyway, it's good to find light amid the darkness. Papen is an aristocrat. He's from the Catholic Centre Party. Again, very Catholic. Bizarrely, he'd been expelled from the United States for spying during the First World War. He married the daughter of a rich industrialist. So he's rich. He's very well connected.
但无论如何，在黑暗中寻找光明是件好事。帕彭是个贵族。他来自天主教中央党。同样，非常天主教。奇怪的是，他在第一次世界大战期间曾因间谍活动被美国驱逐出境。他娶了一位富有实业家的女儿。所以他很富有。他有着极广的人脉。
He's posh. He knows everybody. He has contacts in every- So he's very, He's very well connected. He's posh. He knows everybody. He has contacts in every... So he's very, very different to Hitler then. Completely different. Utterly different. Yeah. He knows lots of people in the army.
他很有权势。他认识所有人。他在各个——所以他非常，他有着极广的人脉。他很有权势。他认识所有人。他在各个……所以他跟希特勒非常非常不一样，对吧？完全不同。截然不同。是的。他在军队里认识很多人。
He knows lots of people in politics, in big business. Interestingly, we talked about Brüning and our old chum Antonio Salazar from the Portuguese episodes. Frans von Papen has a lot of this going on as well. There's a sort of Catholic political authoritarianism very common in Europe in the 1920s and 1930s. Von Papen and the people around him actually talk about a new state, which is the same, you know, they call it the Estado Novo in Portugal.
他在政界、大企业里认识很多人。有趣的是，我们讨论了布吕宁和我们在葡萄牙那几集中的老朋友安东尼奥·萨拉查。弗朗茨·冯·帕彭身上也有很多这种特质。这是20世纪20年代和30年代在欧洲非常常见的一种天主教政治威权主义。冯·帕彭和他身边的人实际上在谈论一个新的国家，这和他们在葡萄牙称之为“新国家”（Estado Novo）的东西是一样的。
They dream of this kind of Catholic order returning to Germany. Of course, it's never going to happen because there's so many Protestants in Germany. But anyway, Hindenburg makes him chancellor, and he fills his cabinet with other people like him. So people call it the Cabinet of Barons. Some people call it the Cabinet of Experts, which is very sort of anti-Gove. But I think the Cabinet of Barons is a better- That's much funnier.
他们梦想着这种天主教秩序重返德国。当然，这永远不会发生，因为德国有太多的新教徒。无论如何，兴登堡让他担任总理，并在内阁中塞满了像他一样的人。所以人们称之为“男爵内阁”。有些人称之为“专家内阁”，这非常反戈夫。但我认为“男爵内阁”是一个更好的——这滑稽多了。
I mean, I suppose darkly funny. Well, you'd think of a baron as kind of ruthlessly efficient, wouldn't you? But these barons are all... Yes. Like the Red Baron. Yeah. Van Pappen is in.
我的意思是，可以说是黑色幽默。好吧，你会认为男爵具有冷酷的高效，对吧？但这些男爵全都是……是的。就像红男爵一样。是的。冯·帕彭上台了。
I think it's fair to say he, like General Schleicher, he's an intriguer, and I don't believe he has the slightest idea how to get Germany out of the mess that it is in. An effete Machiavelli, Burley describes him as. That is brilliant. I mean, that is exactly what he's a dilettante. He's a man from the Daily Telegraph. There's a brilliant example in Richard Evans' book.
我认为可以公平地说，他和施莱谢尔将军一样，是个阴谋家，而且我认为他根本不知道如何把德国带出目前的泥潭。伯利将他描述为一个软弱的马基雅维利。这太绝了。我的意思是，这正是他的写照，他是一个业余爱好者。他是一个来自《每日电讯报》的人。理查德·埃文斯的书里有一个精彩的例子。
He says one of Papin's great initiatives is to abolish the guillotine, which has been used since the French Revolution, because he regards it as too newfangled, and to replace it with the traditional Prussian handheld axe for executions. That's very Daily Telegraph, isn't it? Very Daily Telegraph. But it's absolutely not Germany's priority in 1932. No.
他说帕彭的一项重大举措是废除自法国大革命以来一直使用的断头台，因为他认为这太新潮了，并用传统的普鲁士手持斧头来代替它执行死刑。这非常《每日电讯报》，对吧？非常《每日电讯报》。但这绝对不是1932年德国的当务之急。没有。
Pappen and Schleicher, so they team up for the time being. The intriguing general and the intriguing effete. What was he in an effete? Machiavelli. Yet again, they persuade President Hindenburg to dissolve the Reichstag and call new elections. I mean, why people keep on doing this? This is great error.
帕彭和施莱谢尔，他们暂时结成了同盟。那个阴谋家将军和那个阴谋家软弱分子。他到底算是个什么软弱的？马基雅维利。他们又一次说服兴登堡总统解散帝国议会并提前大选。我的意思是，为什么人们要一而再再而三地这么做？这是一个巨大的错误。
I mean, even though it's more left-leaning. Famously, the definition of insanity is to keep repeating the same mistake over and over again, expecting it to come out differently. It's strange when you read the accounts, especially by kind of, you know, sort of left-leaning historians like Richard Evans, who keep saying, they keep basically saying,
我的意思是，尽管它更倾向于左翼。众所周知，疯狂的定义就是不断重复同样的错误，却期望得到不同的结果。当你阅读那些记载时，尤其是由理查德·埃文斯等左翼历史学家所写的记载时，会觉得很奇怪，他们不断地在说，他们基本上一直在说，
why do they not just prorogue the parliament forever and impose some kind of authoritarian rule? Why do they keep making these terrible mistakes? Anyway, they do this. Presumably, the alternatives,
为什么他们不索性永远休会并实施某种形式的威权统治呢？为什么他们总是犯这些可怕的错误？无论如何，他们还是这么做了。据推测，替代方案是，
as we now see, is a kind of authoritarian military dictatorship or the Nazis. And because we know which is the kind of authoritarian military dictatorship or the nazis and because we know which is the worst of those yeah you're right we're tempted to see it as the worst of all fates but they you know to repeat they don't know that you're right of course but they're also i mean they do want a military dictatorship but they're kind of frightened that they won't get to do it themselves that somebody else will take it over they're also frightened of alarming the public
正如我们现在所看到的，是一种威权军事独裁或者是纳粹。并且因为我们知道哪一种是威权军事独裁或者纳粹，并且因为我们知道哪一种是所有命运中最糟糕的，是的，你说得对，我们倾向于把它看作是所有命运中最糟糕的，但他们（我要重申）并不知道这一点，你说得当然对，但他们也——我的意思是，他们的确想要军事独裁，但他们又有点害怕自己无法掌控局面，害怕别人会把权力夺走。他们也害怕惊动公众
and provoking civil war so they want to get they want to put themselves in a position where there won't be anybody in the street complaining, where everybody would be delighted, where they've got maybe backing the Reichstag for it. They call new elections. They're conscious of Hitler and his strength. And they think to themselves, listen, we don't want to really alienate him. So they lift, there's been a ban on the stormtroopers marching openly. They say, we'll lift this ban because this will appease him, buy him off and maybe make him an ally. What could possibly go wrong? What could possibly go wrong?
并引发内战，所以他们希望把自己置于这样一个位置：街上不会有任何人抱怨，每个人都会欣喜若狂，也许还能在帝国议会里获得支持。他们宣布重新大选。他们意识到了希特勒及其力量。他们心里想：听着，我们其实不想疏远他。于是他们解除了此前对冲锋队公开游行的禁令。他们说：我们将解除这个禁令，因为这可以安抚他、收买他，也许还能让他成为我们的盟友。能出什么岔子呢？能出什么岔子呢？
Well, almost immediately in July 1932, there's enormous fighting in a place called Altona in Prussia, which is near Hamburg, between the stormtroopers and the communist Red Front. And 18 people are killed and hundreds of people are injured because the police lose control and they start shooting wildly. And Papen then makes another of these terrible, terrible mistakes. Instead of doing what he should have done, which is to ban all the paramilitaries completely, he thinks, great, I can use this as an opportunity
好吧，几乎就在1932年7月，在普鲁士一个靠近汉堡名叫阿尔托纳的地方，冲锋队和共产党红卫阵线之间爆发了激烈的冲突。有18人死亡，数百人受伤，因为警察失去了控制，开始疯狂开枪。随后帕彭又犯下了另一个极其可怕、极其严重的错误。他本应该做的是彻底禁止所有的准军事组织，但他却没有这么做，反而认为：太好了，我可以利用这个机会
to seize control of the state government of Prussia. So Prussia is the England of Germany. It dominates Germany. It's by far the biggest state. If you control Prussia, you don't quite control the lot, but you're a lot of the way there. And Prussia is run by the Social Democrats. And basically, von Papen and Hindenburg dissolve by emergency decree
来夺取普鲁士州政府的控制权。所以普鲁士就是德国的英格兰。它主导着德国。它是迄今为止最大的州。如果你控制了普鲁士，你虽然不能完全控制整个国家，但也八九不离十了。而普鲁士是由社会民主党人执政的。基本上，冯·帕彭和兴登堡通过紧急法令解散了
the Social Democratic, they take over the Social Democratic government of Prussia, they kick out the Social Democrats from their great stronghold, and von Papen will use this as his own personal fiefdom. And this is a disaster for democracy because here you have the central government unconstitutionally effectively getting rid of the biggest party and the Social Democrats do nothing to resist it.
社会民主党政府，他们接管了普鲁士的社会民主党政府，把社民党人从他们的大本营里赶了出去，而冯·帕彭将把这里作为他个人的封地。这对民主来说是一场灾难，因为在这里，中央政府实际上以违宪的手段摆脱了最大的政党，而社民党人却没有做任何抵抗。
Why do they not resist it? Because they're worried about civil war as well? They are, exactly. The Social Democrats are paralysed. But they've been paralysed the whole way through, haven't they? I mean, they've been kind of sitting there waiting for the revolution to come
为什么他们不抵抗呢？因为他们也担心内战吗？正是如此，社民党人瘫痪了。但他们从头到尾都处于瘫痪状态，不是吗？我的意思是，他们一直坐在那里等待革命的到来，
and nothing ever happens. It's that, but also they've known from the very beginning of Weimar that lots of people in the army don't like them, that there are lots of reactionaries who think they're illegitimate. I mean, they've known this from even before the First World War. And at this key moment, they do nothing. They don't have a general strike. They're being robbed of their heartland.
却什么也没发生。不仅如此，他们从魏玛共和国一开始就知道，军队里有很多人不喜欢他们，有很多反动派认为他们是不合法的。我的意思是，他们在第一次世界大战之前就已经知道了这一点。而在这样一个关键时刻，他们什么也没做。他们没有发动总罢工。他们的大本营正在被掠夺。
You know, I'm trying to imagine an analogous situation. It's as though there was an elected English government that the Westminster Parliament suddenly kicked out and said, we'll run it ourselves, in a context of street violence. And that government did nothing about it. Didn't say, oi, this is illegal. Take to the streets, have a general strike or something.
你知道，我在努力想象一个类似的情况。这就好像在街头暴力的背景下，威斯敏斯特议会突然赶走了一个通过选举产生的英国政府，并说：我们自己来运行它。而那个政府对此毫无作为。没有说：喂，这是非法的。走上街头，举行总罢工什么的。
So they can't have a general strike because unemployment is so high that you know people aren't going to down tools to go out on the streets so as as richard evans says parpins coup dealt a mortal blow to the weimar republic it destroyed the federal principle and opened the way to the wholesale centralization of the state which the nazis are all about. Of course. Because if you have a Führer. So if the Nazis ever do take power, they can follow that precedent. So the election.
所以他们无法举行总罢工，因为失业率太高了，你知道人们不会放下工具走上街头的，所以正如理查德·埃文斯所说，帕彭的政变对魏玛共和国造成了致命的打击，它摧毁了联邦原则，为国家全面集权铺平了道路，而这正是纳粹梦寐以求的。理所当然。因为如果你有一个元首。所以如果纳粹真的夺取了政权，他们就可以遵循这个先例。所以这场选举。
This election in July 1932 that von Papen has called takes place in a context of where we began with horse vessel and the street violence. This is now worse than ever before. So Hitler is again flying around, addressing different venues. The propaganda is more aggressive than ever. I mean, Richard Evans is brilliant on this, actually. He says every poster, no matter what party it's for,
冯·帕彭呼吁的1932年7月的这次选举，发生在霍斯特·韦塞尔和街头暴力开端的背景下。这比以往任何时候都要糟糕。所以希特勒又坐着飞机到处跑，在不同的地方发表演讲。宣传比以往任何时候都更具攻击性。我的意思是，理查德·埃文斯在这方面的论述实在太精彩了。他说每一张海报，无论它是哪个党派的，
basically looks the same. It's a giant half-naked male worker smashing his adversaries. He says all over Germany, electors were confronted with violent images of giant workers smashing their opponents to pieces, kicking them aside, yanking them out of parliament, or looming over frock-coated and top-hatted politicians who were almost universally portrayed as insignificant and quarrelsome pygmies.
基本上看起来都一样。那是一个巨大的半裸男工人在痛击他的对手。他说在整个德国，选民们都面临着暴力图像的冲击：巨大的工人们把他们的对手砸成碎片，把他们踢到一边，把他们从议会里拽出来，或者高高耸立在那些几乎被普遍描绘成微不足道、爱吵架的侏儒的、身穿燕尾服头戴大礼帽的政客们上方。
And of course, if everybody's doing that, it plays into the hands of the people who do it best. Of course, yeah. And that's the Nazis. So they run, yet again, they say... And the Nazis are saying, what is their policy? What is their policy to their political opponents? Are they saying, we'll put them in concentration camps,
当然，如果每个人都在这么做，那就正合了那些最擅长此道之人的心意。当然，是的。那就是纳粹。所以他们奔走相告，他们再次宣称……纳粹的政策是什么？他们对政治对手的政策是什么？他们是在说要把他们送进集中营，
we'll ban them? Are they... They're never so explicit. They're never so explicit. They talk in abstractions. They say, we'll end the parliamentary pygmies and their bickering, national unity, national rebirth, down with the Jewish financiers,
我们要取缔他们吗？他们是……他们从来没有这么明确过。他们从来没有这么明确过。他们谈论的都是抽象的概念。他们说，我们要结束议会侏儒及其争吵，实现民族团结，民族复兴，打倒犹太金融家，
down with the communists, down with the November criminals. Right, but when they say down with the communists, what are they saying they're going to do to the communists? They're not specific. They're never specific. So even if you read Mein Kampf, Tom, I mean, Hitler is all generalities. It's all kind of the language, the medical language that we've talked about a lot in this series,
打倒共产党，打倒十一月罪犯。对，但当他们说打倒共产党时，他们说的是他们要对共产党做什么？他们没有具体说明。他们从来不具体。所以即使你读《我的奋斗》，汤姆，我的意思是，希特勒满篇都是泛泛而谈。全都是那种我们在本系列中讨论过很多次的语言，
or the sort of slightly religious language that you are obviously familiar with from your stuff with Horse Vessel. You know, that sort of talk of rebirth and national salvation. It's all that sort of stuff. And that election, 31st of July, it is an absolute disaster for the mainstream and a victory for the extremes. So the Nazis double their vote, 6 to 13 million. They're now by far the biggest single party in the Reichstag, 230 seats.
或者是那种你从关于霍斯特·韦塞尔的材料中显然很熟悉的略带宗教色彩的语言。你知道，那种关于复兴和民族拯救的言论。全都是这类东西。而那场7月31日的选举，对主流派别来说是一场绝对的灾难，对极端派别来说则是一场胜利。所以纳粹的得票率翻了一番，从600万飙升至1300万。他们现在是帝国议会中当之无愧的单一最大党，拥有230个席位。
The communists also increased their vote. They're on 89 seats. There is a sense, however, this is as good as it will ever get for the Nazis. This was their greater popularity. They've hit the the glass ceiling they've probably hit a ceiling so even goebbels in his diary says you know we've got 37 of the vote it's probable we've got as many people who will ever vote for us in a kind of free election so this is the point at which we should become a party of power we should enter government the issue is is that they don't want to enter government
共产党的得票率也有所增加。他们拥有89个席位。然而，有一种感觉，这对于纳粹来说已经是极限了。这就是他们最大的声望。他们触到了天花板，他们可能已经触到了天花板，所以连戈培尔都在他的日记里写道：你知道，我们得到了37%的选票，这很可能是我们在任何一种自由选举中能得到的支持者的极限了，所以这就是我们应该成为一个权力政党、应该进入政府的时候。问题在于，他们不想以
as anybody else's partner. Well, because Hitler can't, can he? No, you're right. If he's proclaiming himself the Fuhrer, this man of destiny, this kind of Wagnerian hero, he can't sit down with all the frock-coated pygmies and behave like any other politician. Exactly right.
任何其他人的伙伴身份进入政府。好吧，因为希特勒不能这样做，对吧？不，你说得对。如果他自封为元首，这个命运之子，这种瓦格纳式的英雄，他怎么能和所有那些穿着燕尾服的侏儒坐在一起，表现得像任何其他政治家一样呢？完全正确。
I think you're absolutely right, Tom. I think if he's got this sacred destiny to lead Germany into a national revolution, how can you do that if you're sitting with the very people? So he starts to have secret talks with General Schleicher about doing a deal and becoming chancellor. But for various reasons, this is in August 1932, for various reasons, those talks run aground. One reason is that there's yet more extreme street violence.
我想你完全说对了，汤姆。我想如果他肩负着引领德国走向民族革命的神圣使命，如果你和那些人坐在一起，你怎么能做到这一点呢？于是他开始与施莱谢尔将军进行秘密会谈，商讨达成协议并由他出任总理。但出于各种原因——这是在1932年8月——由于各种原因，这些会谈搁浅了。原因之一是发生了更多极端的街头暴力事件。
Papen has just announced the death penalty for all political crimes, basically to use it against the communists. Presumably with an axe, yes. Prussian axe. So that's something to cheer the traditionalists up. Yeah. The letter writers of the day will be delighted with that. Papen wants this.
帕彭刚刚宣布对所有政治犯罪判处死刑，基本上是想用它来对付共产党人。大概是用斧头，是的。普鲁士战斧。所以这倒能让传统主义者们欢呼雀跃一番。是的。当时的信件作家们会对这一点感到欣喜若狂的。帕彭想要这个。
He tends to use this against the communists. However, the first crime that happens within hours of the law being passed is a load of Nazi brown shirts killing a communist in an Upper Silesian village, and five of them are sentenced to death. Hitler goes absolutely mad and says, how can I work with anybody who sentences our people to death? They're not criminals.
他倾向于用这个来对付共产党人。然而，在该法律通过后数小时内发生的第一个罪案，是一帮纳粹冲锋队员在西里西亚北部的一个村庄里杀死了一名共产党人，其中五人被判处死刑。希特勒气急败坏地说：我怎么能跟任何判处我们的人死刑的人合作？他们不是罪犯。
They're fighting for the fatherland. Against this background, Hindenburg still has slightly cold feet about dealing with it. I mean, Hindenburg is, what did I say? Last time he was 84. Now he's, I mean, he's 85 going on 127 yeah he's still a bit iffy about this he has a key meeting on the 13th of august 1932 with hitler the presidential palace he says i want you to serve under franz von papen hitler says no no i want to be chancellor i have to be chancellor i'm leading the biggest party
他们是在为祖国而战。在这种背景下，兴登堡对于如何处理此事仍然有些三心二意。我的意思是，兴登堡，我刚才说什么来着？上次他84岁。现在他，我的意思是，他85岁快要127岁了，是的，他对此仍然有点犹豫不决。他在1932年8月13日与希特勒在总统府举行了一次关键会谈，他说：我希望你在弗朗茨·冯·帕彭手下任职。希特勒说：不，不，我想当总理，我必须当总理，我是最大党的领袖。
and hindenburg says no and and he says something which he should say. He says, I will not hand over the Reich to one party that is so intolerant and that encourages violence. I will not do it. And the meeting lasts just 20 minutes and Hitler goes out. Furious that Hindenburg has said no it's that meeting is largely forgotten today in his biography Ian Kershaw says that should have been that yet again that was hit this chance it was gone is that when Hitler plunges into his big depression I think well yeah I guess he does plunge into a big depression then yes because he feels he's had his chance and it slipped through and it's and yeah and he's blown it well it's not that he's blown it. It's that the one man that he couldn't circumvent, the war hero, the one man who really is, you know, the guardian of the constitution,
而兴登堡说：不。并且他说了一番他本该说的话。他说：我不会把帝国交给一个如此不宽容并鼓励暴力的政党。我绝不这么做。这场会谈仅持续了20分钟，希特勒就出去了。愤怒于兴登堡说了不。那次会谈在今天大体上已被遗忘。伊恩·克肖在他的传记中说，那本该是——又一次，那是希特勒的机会，它就这样溜走了。那是希特勒陷入深度抑郁的时候吗？我想——好吧，是的，我想他当时确实陷入了深度抑郁，是的，因为他觉得自己失去了这个机会，它从指缝中溜走了，而且——是的，他搞砸了。好吧，倒不是说他搞砸了。而是唯一一个他无法绕过的男人，那位战争英雄，唯一一个真正是，你知道的，宪法守护者的人，
if he can't persuade Hindenburg to give him a chance, he has no hope, unless he sort of kills Hindenburg or something, or Hindenburg waits till he's dead. But if he waits till he's dead, Germany will have recovered from the depression by then or be in the recovery, and then Arsene's momentum will have passed. So that should be that for Hitler, but of course it isn't. So what happens next is pure intrigue.
如果他无法说服兴登堡给他一个机会，他就毫无希望了，除非他干掉兴登堡之类的人，或者等兴登堡自然死亡。但如果他等到兴登堡死了，德国到那时就已经从大萧条中恢复过来或者正在复苏中，那么纳粹的势头就将一去不复返了。所以对希特勒来说，这本该是结局，但事实并非如此。所以接下来发生的事情纯粹是阴谋。
Papen has a plan that he will, let's just dissolve the Reichstag forever. Let's just get rid and use Hindenburg's presidential emergency powers to rule by decree. And that will pave the way for an authoritarian regime that we've always dreamed of, that we've wanted since 1918. There's an incredible moment. It's pure parliamentary drama. Von Papen goes to the Reichstag on the 12th of September, 1932, to dissolve it, to basically set this in train. But before he can do that, the communists place a vote of no confidence in the government. And to Von Papen's horror and fury, the Nazis, the biggest party who are basically running it, so Goering is the sort of president of the session goering says we'll vote on the no confidence thing first they vote on it
帕彭有一个计划，那就是，让我们干脆永远解散帝国议会。让我们一不做二不休，利用兴登堡的总统紧急权力通过法令进行统治。这将为我们一直梦想的、自1918年以来一直渴望的威权政体铺平道路。这是一个令人难以置信的时刻。这简直是纯粹的议会戏剧。冯·帕彭于1932年9月12日来到帝国议会将其解散，基本上是为了启动这一切。但在他能够这么做之前，共产党人对政府提出了不信任投票。令冯·帕彭惊恐和愤怒的是，纳粹——这个基本上在操纵局面的最大党派，戈培尔——不对，戈培尔是会议的主席，戈培尔说：我们先对不信任案进行投票。他们进行了投票，
and they the no confidence wins by 512 votes to 42 so pop and his government completely what's a ringing defeat isn't it a very ringing defeat they're completely humiliated how can you now dissolve it and rule by decree when you've been so completely rebuked and shown that you have no democratic legitimacy at all? And so Papen and co, they kind of lose their bottle. And yet again, they say, well, we'll have another election. Oh, I'll bang my head against his door again. Everybody is sick of elections by now. Actually, the Nazis now are beginning to drop. This is the incredible thing, Tom.
不信任案以512票对42票获胜，所以帕彭和他的政府彻底——这是一次惨败，不是吗？是一场彻头彻尾的惨败。他们完全被羞辱了。既然你已经被彻底痛斥，并表明你根本没有任何民主合法性，你怎么还能解散议会并通过法令统治呢？于是帕彭一伙人有点泄气了。他们又一次说：好吧，我们再进行一次大选。哦，我又要拿脑袋去撞南墙了。到这个时候，所有人都对选举厌烦透顶了。事实上，纳粹现在开始走下坡路了。这就是不可思议的地方，汤姆。
The Nazis took power after they were dropping. Their vote drops from 13.7 million votes to 12.7 million. They lose 44 seats. They are still the biggest party, but now they are smaller than the Social Democrats and the Communists combined. The Communists are going up all the time, by the way, they're now up to 100. But the Communists and the Social Democrats won't work with each other.
纳粹夺取政权是在他们走下坡路之后发生的。他们的得票率从1370万票下降到1270万票。他们失去了44个席位。他们依然是最大党，但现在他们的规模已经小于社会民主党和共产党的总和。顺便说一句，共产党的势头一直在上升，他们现在达到了100个席位。但共产党和社会民主党是不会合作的。
They'll never work together. They hate each other. More than they hate the Nazis. Well, is it more than they hate the Nazis? As much as. I think it's certainly fair to say. So what happens now? Total stasis.
他们永远不会合作。他们恨对方。甚于恨纳粹。好吧，真的是甚于恨纳粹吗？差不多吧。我认为这样说绝对是公正的。那么现在会发生什么呢？彻底的停滞。
Nobody knows. And just pure factionalism. So Papen and Schleicher, so the effete Machiavelli and the intriguing general, they've kind of fallen out with each other. They both want to be running Germany. They're more interested basically in their own personal fortunes than they are in thinking about what the Nazis truly represent. Schleicher says to Papen, you've got to go, mate.
没有人知道答案。只有纯粹的派系斗争。所以帕彭和施莱谢尔，也就是那个软弱的马基雅维利和那个阴谋家将军，他们已经彻底闹翻了。他们都想统治德国。比起考虑纳粹真正代表什么，他们显然更关心自己的个人命运。施莱谢尔对帕彭说：你得走了，老兄。
The army's not going to back you anymore. So Papen, you've got to go, mate. The army's not going to back you anymore. So Papen resigns. There's then two weeks of sort of general intrigue. Finally, Schleicher, the general, takes on the chancellorship himself. It's not really what he wanted. I think he wanted a puppet to do it for him. Hindenburg, by now, is very distrustful of General Schleicher. He thinks General Schleicher has been plotting against Papen all this time.
军队不会再支持你了。所以帕彭，你得走了，老兄。军队不会支持你了。于是帕彭辞职了。随后是两周的各种宫廷阴谋。最后，将军施莱谢尔亲自出任总理。这其实并不是他想要的。我想他本想要一个傀儡来为他代劳。此时的兴登堡对施莱谢尔将军非常不信任。他认为施莱谢尔将军这段时间一直在密谋反对帕彭。
Schleicher opens talks with the Nazis. He appeals to Hitler's, I suppose you could say almost Hitler's, rival within the Nazi party, Gregor Strasser, who's tempted. This is such a dangerous thing to be. Very dangerous thing to be, as Gregor Strasser will discover. Strasser is tempted, but the Nazis say, no, you can't do this without hitler so he ends up resigning all his posts and leaving the nazi party inside the hindenburg circle they're all talks the whole time what on earth are we going to do who's going to
施莱谢尔与纳粹展开了会谈。他向希特勒在纳粹党内的——可以说几乎是希特勒的对手格雷戈尔·施特拉瑟发出呼吁，后者动心了。这是一个极其危险的位置。非常危险的位置，正如格雷戈尔·施特拉瑟随后所发现的那样。施特拉瑟动心了，但纳粹说：不，没有希特勒你做不成这事。于是他最终辞去了所有职务并退出了纳粹党。在兴登堡的圈子里，大家一直在讨论：我们到底该怎么办？谁来
run the country and there are lots of conservatives around hindenburg who say you can't trust general schleicher you know von papen was quite good get him back you know more of the stuff with the axe bring i mean he's conservative we can trust him they never think they never think why don't we bring the kaiser back no i think the kaiser is completely uh so he's off in holland isn't he he's off in holland becoming very anti-semitic well there's a kaiser who previously in his previous appearances and the rest is history has been very much a comic figure. I think it's fair to say that against this backdrop, it's hard to see him in quite the same entertaining light as previously.
治理这个国家？兴登堡身边有很多保守派说：你不能信任施莱谢尔将军，你知道的，冯·帕彭其实挺不错的，把他弄回来，你知道的，再把那套斧头的把戏搬出来。我的意思是他是保守派，我们可以信任他。他们从没想到——他们从没想过：为什么不把德皇请回来呢？不，我觉得德皇完全——所以他在荷兰，对吧？他在荷兰变得非常反犹太主义。好吧，有一个德皇，他此前在之前的出场以及“余下的都是历史”中，一直非常像一个喜剧人物。我想说的是，在这种背景下，很难再以过去那种娱乐的眼光来看待他了。
So the Hindenburg Circle decide, okay, let's talk to the Nazis after all. And they do it through the press baron, Alfred Hugenberg, nationalist press baron, who I talked about in the previous podcast. Von Papen is this great intriguer. He is the key figure. They have talks with Hitler. They say, maybe we'll put you in as chancellor after all. But most of your cabinet have to be conservative. It's not Nazis. Meanwhile, they hear talks that Schleicher, General Schleicher, may be planning
所以兴登堡的圈子决定，好吧，归根结底还是跟纳粹谈谈吧。他们通过报业大亨阿尔弗雷德·胡根贝格来进行接触，这位民族主义报业大亨我在上一期播客中提到过。冯·帕彭这个伟大的阴谋家。他是关键人物。他们与希特勒进行了会谈。他们说：也许我们最终还是会让你当总理。但你内阁的大多数人必须是保守派。不能全是纳粹。与此同时，他们听到传闻说施莱谢尔，施莱谢尔将军可能在策划
some sort of coup. So they're very exercised by this. They say, we must hurry, we must hurry. We must get, you know, we must sort this out so that Schleicher doesn't get in instead. I mean, it's pure court politics. The ideological divisions between Hindenburg, Pap and Schleicher are minimal. It's all Game of Thrones. Yeah, it's very Game of Thrones. And Ian Kershaw says in his biography,
某种政变。所以他们对此感到非常焦虑。他们说：我们必须抓紧，我们必须抓紧。我们必须让——你知道，我们必须把这事定下来，以免施莱谢尔抢先一步。我的意思是，这纯粹是宫廷政治。兴登堡、帕彭和施莱谢尔之间的意识形态分歧微乎其微。这完全就是《权力的游戏》。是的，非常《权力的游戏》。伊恩·克肖在他的传记中说，
you know, even at this point, if they had basically stopped intriguing against each other, if Hindenburg had just said, listen, this is a shambles, let's dissolve the Reichstag, go on, Schleicher, have a go, run the country, rearm, do what you like, be a bit authoritarian, the Nazi regime could have been averted. But again, they don't know.
你知道，即使到了这个时候，如果他们基本上停止互相阴谋算计，如果兴登堡当时只是说：听着，这简直是一团糟，让我们解散帝国议会，去吧，施莱谢尔，放手去干，治理国家，重新武装，随你便，稍微独裁一点，纳粹政权本是可以避免的。但话又说回来，他们并不知道。
No. But that is a worse alternative. No, they don't. Because Schleicher thinks, you know what? The Nazis maybe aren't so bad. I'll probably end up running the army. The Italy army will run things anyway. So, you know, who cares?
不。但这将是一个更糟糕的替代方案。不，他们不知道。因为施莱谢尔心想：你知道吗？纳粹也许也没那么糟。我最后可能会去掌管军队。反正意大利军队也会接管一切。所以，谁在乎呢？
And von Papen, he is convinced that he's been chancellor already. He thinks, you know, Hitler, this two-bit Austrian, it's fine. I'll be his vice chancellor and I'll run things and the cabinet will be full of my friends. So it is that on the 22nd of January, 1933, there is a crucial secret meeting between Hitler and Papen
而冯·帕彭，他坚信自己曾经当过总理。他心想：你知道的，希特勒这个无名小卒奥地利人，没事的。我会当他的副总理，由我来掌管一切，内阁将塞满我的朋友们。于是就在1933年1月22日，希特勒、帕彭与兴登堡的儿子奥斯卡之间进行了一场至关重要的秘密会谈。正是在那次会谈中，他们达成了交易，同意由希特勒担任总理，帕彭担任他的副手。多米尼克，你知道1933年1月22日还发生了什么吗？是一场板球对抗赛吗？不。希特勒去了霍斯特·韦塞尔的墓地，因为希特勒此前没有出席霍斯特·韦塞尔的葬礼，但他去了他的墓地，并在傍晚发表了纪念讲话。
and Hindenburg's son, Oskar. It's at that meeting they do the deal and they agree that Hitler will be the chancellor and Papen will be his deputy. And Dominic, do you know what else happens on the 22nd of January, 1933? Is it some test match? No. Hitler goes to the grave of Horst Wessel because Hitler had not gone to Horst Wessel's funeral, but he goes to his grave and he addresses a memorial service in the evening.
他们播放了理查德·瓦格纳歌剧《诸神的黄昏》中的葬礼进行曲。舞台布满了月桂树、烛台，还有一幅巨大的、超乎真人大小的韦塞尔画像。所以，甚至当他在幕后进行那些见不得光的阴谋诡计之类的事情时，他同时也活跃在公众舞台上，大力宣扬这位纳粹烈士。难道这没有捕捉到纳粹崛起历程中的某种本质吗？即幕后黑手、密室政治的结合——
And they play the funeral march from Gotterdammerung, from Wagner. And the stage is all set with laurel trees, with candelabras, and with a huge larger than life size portrait of Bessel. So even as he is doing his kind of behind the scenes shenanigans and all that kind of stuff, he is also out on the public stage promoting this this nazi martyr well doesn't that capture something about the nazi rise to power that it's the combination of the backstairs back room absolutely intriguing yeah and then these sort of lurid pseudo-religious theatrical spectacles so yeah so with that so from that moment the deal is done and on the 30th of january uh hitler goes into hindenburg's apartment at the reich's chancellery
绝对的阴谋诡计，是的，然后是这种骇人听闻的、伪宗教的戏剧奇观。所以，是的，就这样——从那一刻起，交易敲定了。1933年1月30日，希特勒走进了位于帝国总理府的兴登堡的公寓。
wilhelm strass if you remember from the first episode yeah renovated and they do the deal and hindenburg says and now gentlemen forwards with god and um somebody says to von Papen about that time, how can you work with these vulgar, stupid, utterly inexperienced, extremely violent sort of common men? Thugs. Thugs. And Papen says, you are wrong. We've hired him. And how wrong he was. Okay. So thank you dominic we will look at the reichstag fire and how hitler outsmarts pappen and hindenburg and everybody and establishes his regime
威廉·施特拉斯，如果你还记得第一集的话，是的，经过了翻新，他们达成了协议，兴登堡说：“现在，先生们，在上帝的指引下前进吧。”然后有人对冯·帕彭说起那件事：“你怎么能和这些粗俗、愚蠢、极其缺乏经验、极其暴力、像是平民阶层的家伙们合作？”暴徒。暴徒。而帕彭说：“你们错了。我们已经雇用了他。”然而他是多么大错特错啊。好了。谢谢你，多米尼克，接下来我们将探讨国会纵火案，以及希特勒如何智胜帕彭、兴登堡和所有人，并最终建立起他的政权，
until he ends up dead outside his bunker in 1945. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
直到1945年他在地堡外死去。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及海量的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并向你揭示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场演出门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。